le raid est souvent ce genre
d'expérience qui vous changent et celui
de l'arbre vert ne déroge pas à la règle
et 240 participants ils enchaîneront
pendant cinq jours course à pied vtt
canoë au tir à l'arc dans ce coin de
paradis au milieu de l'océan indien
l'île maurice mais le raid n'est pas
seulement un défi physique
c'est aussi une aventure humaine à 37
ans émile niveau participe à son
troisième raid marquée par une première
épopée inoubliable le premier jour est
on a croisé des tortues dans l'eau et
c'était vraiment on s'est arrêté pour
prendre des photos totalement c'était
surprenant et ça ça donne vraiment envie
de repartir quoi pour vivre des choses
identiques
de son côté sabrina qu'ils le découvrent
à 33 ans
à quelques jours du départ la patience
diète prend le dessus sur les derniers
imprévus on est passé par plusieurs
phases mais a maintenant qu'on a
vraiment notre équipe qu'on ait trois là
on a vraiment envie d'y aller là on est
impatiente
on sait attention de pas trop se blesser
parce que faut s'entraîner mais voilà on
n'a pas envie de se blesser avant de
partir donc là on veut on veut partir on
veut y aller quand sport et solidarité
se rejoignent c'est aussi ça
l'expérience du raid solidaire
l'équipe de sabrina qui n a choisi
d'aider les enfants de l'île maurice
dans ses valises cette chef de projet
informatique ne transportera pas que du
matériel
on s'est lancé un défi supplémentaire un
défi humanitaire c'est à dire qu'on
emmène là bas des jeux d'éveil des jeux
pédagogiques des livres des fournitures
scolaires pour les enfants de l'île
maurice après ils défilent en bas du
sport c'est le dépassement de soi c'est
vraiment aller voir jusqu'où on peut
aller dépasser ses limites
le raid c'est aussi un état d'esprit où
la cohésion d'équipé capitale emilie
beau pourtant triathlète de formation ne
s'arrête pas la seule performance
sportive souvent primordial les hommes
parfois samedi au match on les aime pas
trop con
ou puisse éventuellement les doubler ce
qui arrive il faut le dire est donc là
ça enlève ce côté justement max aue on
est qu'entre filles il ya vraiment un
esprit de solidarité
on s'aide des qualifi qui crève ou qui
vraiment un souci c'est à les périodes
de vendée globe oblige la voile
s'inscrit au programme décollage pour
l'enfer au paradis
le 25 novembre